78 of women want to date a man who is as
educated or as employed as they are this
is just a straight up imbalance and this
is what I've called the tall girl
problem so Chris Williamson he is an
entrepreneur former club promoter turned
podcaster with more than 70 million
downloads how did I get here Chris are
you aware of the dark side that's
driving you
really want to go here I've been
chronically unpopular throughout all of
school badly bullied didn't have a group
of friends so I'd compromised an awful
lot of who I truly was to try and just
be as popular and successful in that
world as possible but there was a
ambient sense that something is broken
with me in a journal I've got a couple
of different entries and it just put I
think I'm lonely 15 of men say that they
have zero close friends where did we go
wrong with the world of social
connection has been made less and less
social the single biggest predictor of
your health outcomes in life are the
number of close connections that you
have it's more than going to the gym
it's more than stopping drinking people
that are in relationships have better
health outcomes but one in three men
between the ages of 18 and 30 hasn't had
sex in the last year 80 of men report
not approaching a woman because they are
scared of being seen as creepy and by 20
40 45 of 25 to 45 year old women will be
single and childless you can start to
see how this imbalance could cause a
problem this is a very difficult
conversation the first thing that we
need to do is
before this episode starts I have a
small favor to ask from you two months
ago 74 of people that watch this channel
didn't subscribe we're now down to 69 my
goal is 50 so if you've ever liked any
of the videos we've posted if you like
this channel can you do me a quick favor
and hit the Subscribe button it helps
this channel more than you know and the
bigger the channel gets as you've seen
the bigger the guests get thank you and
enjoy this episode
Chris
[Music]
you do a lot of things
and you do a lot of things very very
well
one of the struggles I had when thinking
about how to
direct this conversation was really like
understanding because you're so diverse
in your thinking and your ideas and the
subject matter that you're curious about
how to try and encapsulate exactly who
you are so I guess the question I wanted
to start with is in your own words what
is your mission
I'm a very curious person I always have
been and
I now have the opportunity with my
podcast modern wisdom to
commercialize utilize weaponize that
so that I can bring people in that I'm
interested in so a good example I did a
masters and a bachelor's degree at Uni
in business and I always regretted not
going and doing philosophy or psychology
and in retrospect it always made me
resentful of
uni a little bit because I'd spent all
of this time learning stuff that didn't
teach me anything about the business
world
but then upon starting the podcast what
I realized was that I've been able to
design my perfect University degree with
the top lecturers on the planet and I
get to do it three times a week at the
Cadence that I want and not only do I
get the lecturers that I want but I get
to ask them about the specific area of
their work that I want as well so it's
curiosity the thing that drives me is
curiosity the reason that I do this is
because
I want to know I want to know about
everything I want to know about why the
guy that was sat next to us at dinner
last night decided to wear a suit with
like Converse like I want to know what
is it about that uh so curiosity
that answer is um focused on what you
get from it right is there any sort of
an external Mission something that it
gives to the world that you're
particularly and something that provides
you meaning by delivering it to the
world is there is there an answer there
too yeah so toward the end of my 20s I
had a lot of the trappings of success
that maybe society would tell you that
you should have so running this big
nightlife events business which I was
very proud of and still am
but there was something missing despite
the fact that I had the blue tick on
Twitter and the free charcoal toothpaste
and I'd been on love Island and take me
out and people knew my name and I had
you know monetary success and status and
stuff but there was something missing
and I didn't really understand myself
particularly well and I think that
that's a problem that a lot of people
get to especially guys toward the end of
their 20s
they think all of the values that I have
absorbed that are supposed to be the
things that make me happy maybe don't
fulfill me in the way that they were
promised and that required me to do some
reflection and I realized I actually
didn't have very many opinions what I'd
been doing was I'd been playing a role
as this big name on campus party boy
club promoter big dick around town guy
and I'd compromised an awful lot of who
I truly was to try and just be as
popular and successful in that world as
possible Right
what that meant was I didn't really
understand myself I didn't really
understand
my mission or my purpose and now looking
back I realized that all of the steps
that I took to get from where I was to
where I am now which is still like an
adult infant but slightly less so
all of that they are lessons that I can
gift to other people that will help them
to expedite success avoid the pitfalls
do it in less time with less loneliness
with less pain and suffering than I had
to go through to achieve the same thing
and hopefully
by speaking to people that changed my
life that gave me lessons I can then
pass those on to other people and get
them from where I was to somewhere
that's even better than where I am now
okay so take me back what are The
Dominoes that fell all the connecting
dots that took you to that point where
you were the party boy on campus that
was on take me out on TV and running
club nights take me back to the start
what are the most important things I
need to know about that early experience
that took you to that moment
arrive at University in Newcastle and
I've been chronically unpopular
throughout all of school uh pretty badly
bullied pretty alone an only child and
just didn't have a squad didn't have a
group of friends really was successful
in in sports and had a team but didn't
really have a tight group of friends got
to college and that was a little bit
better started to come out of my shell a
little bit but still not much and then
you get to UNI and the same as every
school kid you know you'd go home for
summer and be like I'm going to reinvent
myself and I'm going to be the cool kid
so I arrive at University and
that was a good intersection of a new
opportunity to be a new person and also
maybe a little bit more social ability
start running a nightlife events
business with the guy that I sit next to
in my first ever seminar
after that we get to the stage where
that's very successful very quickly
I immediately tied a lot of my identity
to the first thing I've ever been super
successful in in life which is running a
nightlife I can get renowned I can have
people that need me which is not really
the same as wanting me but they need me
which is close enough so I think right
well if I just throw all of myself into
this business then I'm going to be
accepted by The World At Large and over
the space of the next
10 years or so that meant that I fully
dedicated myself to that mission and we
were very very good at it we expanded
from Newcastle to Manchester multiple
nights per week across multiple cities
and then I did whatever it took to get
more clout as well so take me out then
first season of Love Island first person
through the doors on love Island and I
spend all of this time love Island was
an interesting reflection period because
there was nowhere for me to hide
no distractions no TV no phone no laptop
no friends no books no nothing right
it's just you and this group of people
and the group of people that were in the
love Island Villa were
genuine versions of the person that I
thought I was I thought that I was this
big name on campus party boy and then I
get deposited into this inescapable uh
weapons grade bunker of those party boys
and party girls and I look around and go
ah I'm not supposed to be here
something's off something's discordant
it's not working and then I get out and
it wasn't like and then the skies opened
and I realized that my path was not to
wear small swim shorts on TV uh however
it did make me think it was a very I
call it a fatal dose of contrast that I
was no longer able to hide that there is
something a little bit off here and that
was a good time your Jordan Peterson's
your a Lander button from the school of
likes your Sam Harris is your Joe
Rogan's all coming to the front I start
consuming that stuff and it makes me
think wow I I actually this speaks to me
it helps to educate me
to be better and to understand myself
and that's kind of how I phased out I
suppose when you talk about struggling
in school socially
what was the reason for that have you
ever sort of diagnosed why you didn't
quote unquote fit in in school yeah so
uh quite I think any only child
struggles to be socialized to the level
that they need to in order to have the
same set of social skills that
anyone with a brother or sister does
right like think about how much time you
with a sibling spend arguing hitting
each other going to sleep them knocking
on your door when you're trying to get
ready arguing for the bathroom all of
these tiny little interactions I had
none of that right and even if you spent
every waking moment of free time in
clubs and sports and whatnot that I did
it's going to be hard and then I think
that there is some inherent introversion
in me and it kind of combined for me to
not really understand other kids so I
used to obsess over things like um the
kind of hairstyle that other kids had or
the way that they tied their tie in
school or the type of shoes that they
wore the way that They Carried their bag
which shoulder their bag was on because
I was adamant I would fixate on that and
that would be the reason that they had
friends and I didn't
because I couldn't understand why I
didn't have friends what it was was that
I couldn't socially relate to kids
particularly well because I didn't have
a wide variety of social skills
so I struggled
but I was taking this super attentive
like what is it what's going on it's
trying to assess is it because Steven
wears his watch on his right wrist
instead of his left wrist is it because
of whatever whatever because I was
trying to diagnose what's going on
do you know
what's driving you from you know the
good and the bad the light and the dark
I'm I'm more specifically interested to
start with the dark do you ever have
conversations with yourself about the
when I say dark it's the subjective term
but the dark side that's driving you
absolutely yeah chronically of course I
think anybody that believes that they're
driven by a pure love uh and positive
reinforcement is uh usually confused I
think that
uh there was a study done that looked at
the three most common traits of Highly
Successful People hyper successful
people we're talking top level CEOs the
first one was a crippling sense of
insufficiency the second one was a
superiority complex and the third one
was an ability to have maniacal Focus so
what you have and it's this this
Peterson story which you may be familiar
with
they starve rats and put them into a
tube they attach a spring to the tail of
the Rat so that they can tell how much
force they're pulling with and that
gives a proxy for desire right that's
how much they want it they waft the
smell of cheese in from the front and
the rat pulls toward the cheese you
think these rats are starving they're
going to be pulling very hard
then they take the rats out and they do
another iteration of the study this time
they want the smell of cheese in from
the front and they waft the smell of a
cat in from behind
the rats pull harder what's the lesson
in life not only do you need to run
towards something that you want but you
need to run away from something that you
fear and I've spent I've spoken to 600
High performers on my show right I would
say that on average most of the people
that are unbelievably good at anything
that they do are driven by a fear of
insufficiency not by a perfectly
balanced desire for success and
this tension between success and
happiness I think is something that both
me and you are quite
interested in
so
the reason it's interesting is a lot of
the time we sacrifice the thing we want
for the thing which is supposed to get
it right
so if in service of becoming happy we
sacrifice happiness to achieve success
in the hopes that success will make us
happy
if you created an equation of what's
going on and you just removed success
from both sides what are you left with
just happiness now I'm not saying that
you can recant all of your desires for
status and Accolade and striving and
stuff like you need to go out and do
things but I do think that a lot of the
time we over complicate the world and a
lot of it is because
when we're kids our parents will
reinforce our successes by praising us
and we'll criticize us when we fail
which can metastasize as we grow up into
being I am only worthy of love and
acceptance and admiration and praise if
I win
because it causes you to fear being a
loser more than want to be a winner and
winning salves it's like an anesthetic
right that papers over fears of
insufficiency so yeah I mean when I was
a club promoter uh I knew that if I
stood on the front door of a nightclub
that people would need me I want the VIP
bands they want to be in the place where
the pretty girls are they want to get in
for cheaper or a free bottle of vodka or
they they want to skip the queue or
whatever so they need me and then when
you roll it forward to the podcast I
have to be very careful that I don't
just transmute that same energy into
instead of gifting people entry into
nightclubs now I'm gifting them insights
that I've learned Concepts from some
interesting person that's going to
improve their life as we sit around a
dinner table or as we go out for a lunch
or whatever I have to be careful that's
not the case and
for the people that maybe resonate with
this fear of insufficiency and this
requirement to offer the world something
in order for the world to feel like
they're Worthy uh it is possible to
deprogram it it is possible to tune that
volume down but one of the things that
you're going to pay a price with is your
drive because the rat that is running
away from something that it fears will
pull harder than the right that's just
running towards something that it wants
the traits of super competitive people
don't just include the superiority
complex but the crippling anxiety about
being a failure so
this tension between success and failure
is
it is a driver but it's an incredibly
toxic fuel right
to be propelled by fear of insufficiency
can work super well but it it's very
dangerous as a final example Eddie Hall
World's Strongest Man and he retires on
the podium he's holding this trophy in
the air and he's saying this is for you
Nana and his grandma's passed away
recently and he's crying and he's 200
kilos and six foot four and you know
he's worked his entire life and he said
in an interview shortly afterward that
if he hadn't won the world's strongest
man he would be dead single with no
relationship to his kid because he was
pushing his body so hard with the
lifting and presumably the drugs that he
was taking he was training so much his
relationship with his wife was breaking
down and he was out of the house so much
he had no relationship to his kid Jason
pargan says uh accept that all of your
heroes are full of [__] Your Heroes
aren't Gods they're just regular people
who got particularly good at One Thing
by sacrificing literally everything else
that's the price that you pay for
success and most people wouldn't pay it
that point about reprogramming the toxic
dramas that you have
um I often Ponder with myself I'm like
and when I think about status games and
how status games that you know we often
think that we're over a certain status
game so you know I had a um a guy on my
podcast who talked a lot about the
evolutionary basis of status and how if
you go to an estate in the UK where
there's not a lot of money they'll have
bigger logos on their tracksuits it will
still we'll store great guy
um and then as people get richer and
richer this logos get smaller and
obviously they play a different type of
game right it's about boats and other
things and I that really hit me like a
ton of bricks because I I thought
dressed in all black I really don't have
any I have one material possession you
saw it last night which is the bag I had
on which I'm waiting for it to break
nice bag it's a nice bag yeah um but
outside I thought I'm over status games
and I realized that I'm just playing a
different set of Statistics just to
count the signal yeah the red sneaker
effect it's the reason that the CEO
that's worth a billion can turn up in a
hoodie but the CEO that's worth half a
million still wears a three-piece suit
it's called there's another idea called
the barber pole of status so you can
imagine that people who are at the
absolute top in terms of status they
need to make sure that the people below
them can't be confused for them but they
can counter signal by having the so you
look at the Vagabond style of flares and
Hoodie you know even Essentials uh Yeezy
uh yay stuff all it's almost like hobo
chic
why well it's because I am so cool and
so trendy that I can counter signal off
the top so everyone is playing a status
game everybody is at all times it's just
a case of
what game are you playing and that toxic
Drive the the big shift I've had in my
life is I'm now focusing on something
which is also driving me to a more
fulfilling Place whereas before I was
focusing on like a monetary game where I
was like how much money can I acquire
how much
um how big can I build a business now
I'm focusing it more on things that are
more intrinsically aligned with um that
which that makes me happy so this for
example or writing or DJing for example
but it's still there so my question to
you there's kind of two questions there
is what's your journey been like with
reprogramming that that toxic driving
force or that dark driving force or that
those in feelings of insufficiency and
secondly you said that we can reprogram
it we can dilute it but it comes at the
cost of Drive yeah how does one do such
a thing
so
what I was missing for me personally was
I didn't feel competent in things I
needed to feel like I was competent and
I was proving something to the world
each time that I succeeded why did you
need to feel competent because that
would solve my feelings of insufficiency
for every time that I won we had a good
club night the business was good we
broke a record with entries at the
different event or whatever that would
make me feel yeah wow I'm like less of a
piece of [__] was there a time where you
were made to feel incompetent
I think just chronically through my
childhood of not being super accepted
there was a ambient sense that something
is broken with me something is wrong
because if there wasn't something wrong
I would have friends okay people would
want me right I think that was just a
relatively logical
if this than that statement that came
out of it and um
when it comes to changing that Alex
homozy who had on the show recently as
this great quote where he says
you don't become Confident by shouting
affirmations in the mirror but by having
a stack of undeniable proof that you are
who you say you are outwork yourself
doubt and it wasn't until I had a
project where I could no longer deny
that my efforts were bearing fruits and
that I was becoming competent at
something
it was a crushing amount of volume and
incontrovertible evidence that smashed
my imposter syndrome into the ground it
is
yeah
yeah did the games did the games you
because now you're in a different
differently category but I feel like I'm
supposed to be here I feel like I
deserve to be here you know often my
guests talk about like that voice in
their head which Whispers to them of you
know words of self-doubt and it seems to
me like I'd say 95 of them haven't
managed to shake that in some form it
still shows up at some time in some
place it's still there but it's a lot
quieter A lot quieter and you have to
accept after a while that if you
continue to disprove your imposter
syndrome in the real world
every single time that you're faced with
a challenge you succeed despite the fact
that you were adamant that you were
going to fail or you had fears of
insufficiency or all the rest of it
after a while you have to accept that it
has nothing to do with your competence
and everything to do with your addiction
to feeling like an imposter
you are delusional about your competence
in reverse
every single time that you are faced
with a challenge you succeed every
single time you are faced with a future
challenge you believe that you're going
to fail
it's got nothing to do with your
competence so Rogan calls it um building
a mountain with layers of paint right
incredibly thin each time but after 600
episodes or however many million dollars
of Revenue or whatever you go
maybe there's something to this you know
maybe I don't maybe I'm not a totally
worthless piece of [__]
on that point of how it diminishes one's
Drive have you seen a diminishment in
your drive then as your feelings of
sufficiency have improved
no because I have changed what is
driving me to something which is much
more aligned with who I am so the
Curiosity for me is crippling and I want
to know about everything which the my
desire to learn things is so much
stronger than any fear of insufficiency
or desire for Success was ever going to
be right
that I've just supplanted one toxic type
of drive for one incredibly personal
very
scalable leverageable beautiful kind of
drive that being said there are times
this is I I'm speaking from you know the
perfect version of me that voice that
negative voice comes in
a few times a week it reminds me that I
maybe I'm not supposed to be here I'm
not who I pretend to be but it's getting
quieter and quieter and quieter and I
think it's getting quieter because I
have a stack of undeniable proof that
I'm supposed to be here
do you remember the last time that voice
came in
yeah I think I told you about this last
night uh I was I was on a podcast and my
blood sugar fell through the floor and
what it showed me was that under times
of extreme stress we revert back to a
voice from
somewhere in our past I don't know who
it was I don't know whether it was a an
angry parent or a teacher that was
annoyed at me or whatever but this voice
came in and it said you're not supposed
to be here you were never supposed to be
here you're boring no one cares what
you've got to say you know that you're a
fake everyone's going to find out
everybody's laughing at you nobody likes
you and I thought as I'm talking away on
this show and my head is spinning with
all of this stuff and I'm thinking where
the [__] is this voice come from what
like who who is that I thought that I
transcended this voice however in a high
pressure situation when I felt bad
something came back through so I think
what it does remind me is that there is
always work to be done there's always
something there that's hiding behind and
that becoming a complacent about
personal growth is something that is
going to allow that to seep back in you
talked about the the paint the like the
layers of paint that build confidence
this is something that I've been
particularly compelled by because so
many people that listen to this podcast
struggle with the idea of confidence and
there's a big industry out there as
you've said that says you know look in
the mirror tell yourself you're a
millionaire
um say it three times write it in your
Journal
but then as I reflected in as I've
written in my my book um the thing that
and it relates to what Alex hamosi said
is the thing that I've learned is it's
all evidence for Better or For Worse
stack of undeniable proof and it goes
the other way that evidence that you got
at seven years old when you went up and
tried to do a public speech and everyone
laughed at you it's more it's a thicker
layer right than than one layer of
evidence to say that you're capable it's
a harder layer to sort of strip
um
if there is someone listening now and
they want to
maybe orientate their drive to the
fulfilling Pursuits that you talk about
but also they want to build their
confidence
what advice would you give them I
imagine that's 80 of the listeners
ACT first okay you have to lead with
action because if you are someone that
deals with a crippling sense of
insufficiency
your ability to discount
any good thoughts you have in your mind
is going to be so strong if you're
trying to lead with positivity first I
need to think it wish it believe it and
I will achieve it your set point of
negativity is going to just Crush that
into the ground I'm speaking from
personal experience right as the guy
that was chronically unconfident and
still has you know the Imposter syndrome
that does creep in
you have to start with action it needs
to be okay what would have had to have
happened in a week's time for me to look
back on that week and find pride in
myself
Pride's seen as something that you
should be ashamed of it's one of the
seven deadly sins but David Goggins did
an episode with him a couple of months
ago we could put it in the in the show
notes if people are interested and he
said pride is something that everybody
misses
that having pride in your name your
performance uh the way that you show up
for other people is something that you
can do but you need to do something that
is worthy of being prideful about right
what would have had to have happened in
a week for you to look back on that week
with pride okay maybe stop breaking
promises to yourself when you say I'm
going to wake up tomorrow at 7am and
when the option comes to hit the snooze
button don't do it
there's one win that you've got for the
day
that's action right and it is just you
know it's tried to say that Peterson
clean your room thing but the reason
that that works is that you start with
the smallest ever step and you expand
out from that
you want to become a writer you want to
leave your job and become a writer okay
can you commit to writing one blog post
on sub stack per week for the next three
weeks
that would make you feel like less of a
loser if you did that
action has to come first if you're the
sort of person who is chronically
unconfident because you will drag your
sense of identity behind you Mark Manson
says that identity lags behind our
status by about one to two years
so for both me and you in two years time
we'll go I understand why I was in LA
that day and and look back
start with action and
make small promises to yourself that you
don't break if you had a friend and
every single time that you and your
friend decided that you're going to go
out for dinner that friend either showed
up two hours late or didn't show up at
all you would stop trusting that person
that is the relationship that you have
with yourself you need to be able to
trust your own word and a lot of us
don't because life is very convenient
and it is easy for people to
not stick to the promises that they set
themselves because our ability to be
idealistic is always going to outstrip
reality's ability to deliver that to us
as soon as you posit an ideal you then
begin to compare yourself to that ideal
and true hell is when the person that
you are meets the person that you could
have been
sometimes I Ponder how um you've
probably seen this in your own life I'm
sure you have where you'll have a friend
in your life I've got a couple of
friends back home who
I've tried to help in some way maybe
give some advice when they're struggling
in their hardest times and the advice
has been ineffective and then you've got
another friend who will just need one
idea they'll be listening to your
podcast and one idea will be the seed
that changes their life I often like
think that I over overestimate The Power
of Words because everything you've said
there makes perfect sense
but we both know that 95 maybe more of
people have just received that
it will not convert into any kind of
behavior
and the habit of not doing things is
unbelievably difficult to get past
it's one of the problems with
anyone that listens to your show or my
show you will love being cerebral right
you will love the idea that I can use
cognitive horsepower to just get myself
out of problems and there is a case of
learning as masturbation right and
believing that learning about something
is the same as enacting it and it's not
that's why it has to be action first
a quote from one of my friends that he
uses when he's thinking about a concept
is does this grow corn basically is it
useful tell me how I can use this in my
life
does it grow [__] corn right
this beautifully uh beautiful sounding
concept cognitive bias that helps me
understand the way that my brain works
and my relationship with everybody else
how do I use that in my life give me
something to apply it to and that's why
with the confidence thing
choose promises that you will never
break to yourself I'm going to get up on
time for the next month I am not going
to hit the snooze button
if you do that and you look back in a
month and you go
oh my God that's the first time I've
done that in
forever Maybe
that's a big win
and you can do the James Clay thing
we'll write it on a board we'll track it
what gets like measured etc etc but the
main thing is just keep promises to
yourself
and that is a good way to go from here
is an Insight I learned about I want to
do breath work cold plunge go to the gym
fast until 12 midday get up on time
sunlight in the eyes and whatever it is
right that you want to do
turn it into a promise
don't break the promise
one of the really important things you
said there was about the size of that
first step I was reflecting there on the
way that video games are designed to
make sure that every subsequent level is
not too intimidating that you lose a
motivation but it's not too
um
too small that you lose motivation as
well you can lose motivation on both
ways and so it's the same with
crosswords and video games they get
incrementally more challenging to keep
you engaged the size of that first step
is is I think a central point there
because when people listen to podcasts
with people like me and you or Andrew
huberman and they hear that they've got
to maybe get up at this time go outside
gaze earth like put their feet on the
ground cold Plunge
and again I'm gonna do that and I set
that as my first step I'm set up for
failure yeah how important do you think
the size and the subjective size of that
small that first step you take to build
trust with yourself is and to start that
discipline
the goal isn't to have the perfect daily
routine tomorrow
the goal is to still be winning your
daily routine in 50 years time if you
expand your time Horizon sufficiently
you will realize that very very tiny
steps can compound look at the graph of
mine or your followers on Spotify
especially mine right because I was
doing my show for so long and it's just
nothing nothing nothing nothing
everything
well why well it's because it's latent
leverage it takes so many layers of
paint to get there so yes the first step
has to be incredibly small
do that make it so small that you can't
say no to it
and then what's next and then what's
next so
when I decided that I was going to try
and become a
more virtuous version of me I was going
to start telling the truth I was going
to have a morning routine I was going to
develop a meditation habit I was going
to read all of these things I wanted to
do and none of which I did right toward
the end of my 20s none of which I did
all of which are now the foundation of
of my life over I don't know 1500
meditation sessions and all of the
authors on the
podcast etc etc
I had to do that one step at a time I
didn't have a stable sleep and wake
pattern until covid ever in my adult
life I'd never gone to bed and woken up
at the same time for seven days in a row
until kovid because I was running
nightlife events right
so
if no matter how difficult the setback
is even if you're a shift worker you're
a nurse You're a parent whatever your
challenge is just make the promise to
yourself sufficiently small
that even with that challenge in front
of you you can make it work
I hear that and I'm motivated as a lot
of people will be because that's what
happens you know like a shower as the
cliche goes motivation comes and then it
slowly it slowly washes over us and
slowly starts to fade how do I prepare
or how should I be preparing for the day
where I've heard Chris Williams and
Steve speaking about this and then in
three and a half days time I wake up in
the morning life has happened the kids
screaming my motivation seems to have
escaped me
[Music]
the distinction between discipline on
that day and the motivation I got from
the source
and that came from the inspiration of
this conversation what do I do
discipline needs motivation for
breakfast
you don't need motivation it's great if
it arrives it's some extra fuel on the
fire but discipline is the thing that
you need what would you tomorrow want
you today to do
you tomorrow would want you to keep that
promise to yourself
and it's why discipline is so much more
valuable I remember this conversation
between Joker willink and Sam Harris six
years ago and they're talking about how
you can't fake bravery because if you do
a thing in spite of being scared of
doing the thing that is bravery right
there's no such thing as fake bravery
like you just if you do the thing and
you're scared that's bravery if you
don't do the thing and you weren't
scared that's not bravery right the same
thing goes for discipline doing the
thing in spite of not wanting to do the
thing is discipline right you don't need
motivation to get yourself up to go and
do a thing
make the promise small Build It Up step
by step know that you are going to have
setbacks and this is my favorite rule
from James Clear which is
a habit missed once is a mistake a habit
missed twice is the start of a new habit
never miss two days in a row
so ideally go for a month build it up
but after that if you ever miss one day
go okay that's mistakes are going to
happen tomorrow I double down tomorrow I
go on time absolutely perfect I'm
straight up out of bed or I go to the
gym or I walk the dog or I do my
meditation or whatever
and that's a good heuristic stops errors
snowballing into new habits
what about if I get to day three
it's then in James clear's definition
the start of a new habit do I not just
apply the same thinking that I did when
I missed it on day one
you just need to well I mean if you
don't ever miss two days you shouldn't
be able to get to day three what if I do
that I think about my own fitness
journey I've been working out for the
last three years and there will be a
week where motivation is gone and then
there'll be multiple weeks so there'll
be sometimes it'll be two weeks in a row
where I'm like taking my ass to the gym
but my workout is absolutely atrocious I
might as well have not have gone
um and I do that because I'm trying to
continue the behavior correct in spite
of the motivation well it doesn't change
your worth as a person
you know you you want to do this because
you think that it's good for you because
you believe that it's good for you
because you care about yourself you care
about Stephen and his body and his mind
you want him to have a long and healthy
life and the same for everybody else
that's listening they want to have good
outcomes from the things that they do in
life
you don't need to lambast yourself
because you don't do a thing that is
perfectly designed to make you feel good
okay like you missed three days in a row
we get back on the horse We Go Again
discipline
you talked a second ago about the
fundamentals of your life now the things
you wanted to put in place you reference
meditation and these kinds of things
when I think about the the Chris
Williams that was running those club
nights was on level Island take me out
and the guy that sat in front of me now
if there were a couple of key
fundamental tools or devices that have
taken you from there to the guy sat in
front of me here
and you know what what are those what
are those things and I say this because
you know when people give advice on this
podcast sometimes when in books and
stuff they'll talk to things they think
they're supposed to say but you never
really get the true stuff they'll say oh
meditation I've never heard that before
I'm like for Chris Williams
what took you from from there
to the Chris Williamson San Fran to be
now
getting up on time every day every day
every day and what's what's on time for
you uh seven seven to seven thirty
depending on what time I went to bed so
it'll change each night but I'll set an
alarm and I will get up on time go to
bed and wake up at around about the same
time each day makes a massive difference
go for a morning walk first thing so
sunlight before screen light was
something that I was doing before
huberman talked about the down
regulation of the amygdala response and
the lateral eye movement helps blah blah
blah in the brain I came up on this
because I wanted to go for a walk more
nowhere to get as many steps in as I
could
get up and go for a walk because it just
so many people are
stopped the second they wake up because
they use their phone as their alarm they
roll over they hit the alarm on their
phone and now their phone's in their
hands and now they're in bed for half an
hour doing the cycle through all of
their social media apps sleep with your
phone outside of your bedroom that was
the number one change that I made phone
is outside of the bedroom and I bought
how long have radio alarms been around a
million years right like just get any
kind of alarm clock wake up go for a
walk before you use your phone that will
change so many of the problems that
people encounter because it the
addiction to technology is
primary I think to a lot of people's
challenges in their day
meditation has been interesting for me
it it's definitely helped me to be
calmer to be more peaceful it's not an
insane performance enhancer the breath
work as well I really enjoy doing that
it's not in the same performance
enhancer
um reading I would say some form of
content
absorption that could come from Reading
articles reading books listening to
podcasts listening to audio books
something that pushes your understanding
is very important and for me that's
moved it was books a while ago now it's
more sub-stack articles that I read on
my Kindle for a long time it's always
been podcasts sometimes it's audiobooks
sometimes it's not what about content
creation the other side of that coin and
the obligation to create
what impact has that had on your life
it's everything because
by having to
talk about the things that I learn it
forces me to learn them right until you
can explain something to somebody else
you don't really understand it so okay
prove to me that you understand it
by telling me about it I can't okay well
you don't understand it then so this is
one of the reasons I suggest to people
that they should do a fake podcast with
a friend for 30 minutes every week
phones are outside of the room put one
phone face down on the table press the
record button and just have a
conversation and pretend that people are
watching
welcome back to the show Stephen today
we're going to talk about the UFC or
Tommy Fury and Jake Paul who do you
think is going to win and it forces you
to be rigorous and precise and
consistent with the things that you
believe and it is a forcing function
that synthesizes the things that you're
doing other people might prefer to write
or Draw one of the advantages of doing
it for an audience is that you actually
feel like someone's keeping you
accountable right if it's just oh I'm
going to draw a drawing every week for
my own pleasure as opposed to I'm going
to draw a drawing every week and post it
on my Instagram or I'm going to write a
sub stack article I mean
I have a posting Cadence on the show
Monday Thursday Saturday and if it
wasn't for the fact that I know if I
don't post on those days the audience
can be like hang on a second mate like
it's Monday where's the podcast episode
it would be a lot less motivating for me
to do it
driven by that so I think that
absolutely creating some kind of content
whether it be just for you or whether it
be to put out into the world and to
build a platform with is a
a good start the most important thing I
think in hindsight that I've gained from
content creation is in fact like honing
my skill of sales because you're forced
in this medium to make your ideas as
concise as you possibly can and say them
in a way which is engaging and I've
reflect over the last 10 years or so of
making content and recording videos and
go man the impact it's had on my
business my ability to pitch and sell
but even if you're a guy and you're
looking to pick someone up in a bar man
or woman
it's profound to me the impact that the
obligation to create content
specifically on video in in
um
in speaking form has had on all facets
of my life and I just don't feel like
there's enough of a charge to both
introspect but then the obligation to
create I think it's life-changing
there's a interesting quote from
Wittgenstein Ludwig Wittgenstein and he
says the limits of my language mean the
limits of my world so you could see a
richer vocabulary means a richer life if
you take the fact that you have ideas in
your head that these sort of wishy-washy
ephemeral notes it's like a smell right
an idea is kind of like a smell it's
it's just a amorphous blob of a thing
and you go oh yeah I feel like this I
feel like this is an idea until you make
it take form through spoken word written
word or drawing
doesn't really exist it's not tangible
you can't see it you can't work out
where the holes are in whatever this
idea is so what that means is that first
off the more words that you have in your
Arsenal the more precisely you can
describe the thing which is in your head
the more frictionlessly you can take
ideas from your brain to your mouth your
fingertips or the end of a pencil the
more accurately you're going to be able
to put that out into the world which
means that when you need to turn it over
and assess it and look at it oh my God I
thought that I knew this inside out and
there's this big gaping hole here I need
to work out what's going on which is why
a loneliness epidemic uh the massive
falling rates of friendlessness in in
the world
I'm particularly good because not only
is it bad for the community and for
social cohesion but it's bad for the
individual's personal growth as well if
you want to
fully learn something
you want to spend
time synthesizing your ideas
and you can really only ever do that for
somebody else again you can write the
journal to you for you
but it's never going to be as
disciplined or as consistent as if
you're writing it for an audience even
if the audience is only five people or
only your friends
and you spoke to something which is
because you were outside of the Social
Circle when you were young you were able
to
I guess vicariously see the impact that
small things had which made you kind of
socially attuned talking then about the
loneliness epidemic
is it is it an epidemic how bad is it is
it something that you believe Society
should be paying more attention to I sat
here with Simon sinek the other day and
he disclosed to me that he was going
through a real
struggle with loneliness at the moment
and it was somewhat surprising it was
somewhat surprising because again in a
very naive way Simon sinek is someone of
great success he's got a career most
people would um would die for he's a man
of you know that's greatly admired he
goes on stages and thousands of people
raw his name
but then on a personal level he's lonely
and one of the things he said to me was
there's a real difference between being
alone
and being lonely
do you can you see the distinction
between the two yeah I mean Solitude is
something that many of us enjoy I know
that me and you both enjoy it right
loneliness isn't I used to write I've
got um in a journal that I used to keep
in my phone a couple of different
entries from my mid-20s and it just put
I think I'm lonely
yeah because I just I I couldn't work
out what was going on I had a sense that
it was maybe something that was a little
bit wrong I think I'm lonely
um when it comes to the loneliness
epidemic
uh in 1990 the number of men who said
that they had six or more close friends
was around about 55 in 2020 that dropped
to 21 it's less than half right right 21
of men say that they have less than six
close friends the number of men who say
that they have zero close friends
has
increased by five-fold from 1990 and
it's now at 15 percent
15 of men say that they have zero
close friends I don't know the stats for
women it seems like women are able to
hold on to social groups a little bit
more effectively than men are the
loneliest epidemic does seem to be
hitting man a little bit more hard
I'm compelled by your diary entry
before we get into their stats in the
causation you wrote in your diary in
your mid-20s I think I'm lonely yep it's
funny because I I reflect on my early
20s between 20 and 25.
and I was definitely lonely but I had no
idea until later
that was why I only thought that I was
lonely you know I was like what is it
what were we just saying it's a notion
it's a it's a smell someone shouted it
from the other room [__]
do you think I'm lonely no one's
described it I didn't have a description
of it so I had this sort of
innate this feeling inside my being
but no one had put a word to it before
or told me what the like job description
of someone that's lonely looks like so
it was a signal like something's not
right but I don't know what it is yep
and I only learned when I was not slowly
when I felt a real sense of connection
what I was missing oh [__] that's not
what life's supposed to be like so tell
me about you what what caused that what
factors had come together to put you in
a situation where you were lonely I've
met about a million people in my life
and I only had a handful of friends
that made me think my exposure to friend
conversion seems to be off there is
something not right here and this was
largely due to the fact that I was
playing a role as this big name on
campus party boy and quite rightly who
was I going to resonate with when I
wasn't being me they were going to at
best become friends with a projection of
what I thought they wanted me to be
right so this was almost exclusively on
myself but also I was struggling a
little bit in the industry to find
um the I can't have a conversation about
like the deeper sense of human nature or
the existential pain of being alive or
status from will stored his brand new
book when someone's desperately trying
to get a VIP wristband off me so that
they can go and see the hot girls
downstairs like it's it's not quite the
right environment for that but again
largely this was due to the fact that I
wasn't being sufficiently confident that
other people would be interested in what
I was interested in
and yeah I mean you can be have all of
the success in the world
you can be surrounded by people and yet
feel alone in a crowd and Hollow in
Victory
because if you're only playing a role
anything that you do any love that
people give to you won't feel like it
hits you existentially you'll feel
praise but you won't feel love
because they're not in love with you
they're just applauding the role that
you're playing
does that make sense makes perfect sense
makes perfect sense it's such an app
description it really brings in this
idea of what the person is connecting to
matters the most I.E if they're
connecting to the image that I've
created which is inauthentic to myself
I'm never going to receive that
connection the only way to cure my
loneliness is to show up as myself and
to build connection on that basis which
is again makes a ton of sense to me
because I was a young CEO who had
hundreds of employees
my relationship to them wasn't
necessarily Steve the true sense of
Steve to them so are they the CEO it was
exactly it was CEO to employee and then
in my personal life in the early 20s
phase there was maybe one person maybe
two
that new state that were connected to
Steve but even maybe one actually
um which is super interesting because we
don't it also talks to Simon sinek's
thing where I go well he's this guy's
something amazing of it but how many
people are connected to the true Simon
the guy behind the books the guy behind
the admiration
that study you referenced a second ago
about men getting increasingly lonelier
I I think I read the same thing the
thing I read was about the amount of
people
we have to turn to in a time of Crisis
and how that's decayed over the last
couple of decades
why is that happening what is happening
in culture and Society that's causing us
to become more and more
disconnected in terms of proximity but
also in just in terms of sort of
psychological connection what is going
on it's a good question uh I don't think
that there's a there's a single answer
to this
um social media probably has a lot to
answer for
what's happened now is
the world of
social connection has been made less and
less social right you're more more
connected than ever before but more
atomized than ever before as well I
think that there are some really
worrying Trends in Rising rates of
social anxiety that are mostly
Downstream from people not spending
enough time being social if you look at
the average amount of hours that kids
would have played outside versus the
average amount of hours that kids are
spending watching television on social
media and playing video games now you
are basically creating an army of young
Chris's right that were socially
uneducated in that regard Downstream
does turn into adults that similarly
don't
they haven't got the habits of going out
and being social which means that they
don't develop the skills to connect to
people to be able to make friends and
that causes loneliness like that's
I think a large portion of what we're
talking about what about the like
optimization of our lives and the way
that we've built cities and the way that
we're you know when I say optimization
of Our Lives I mean like
if we order food convenience it's a
screen I mean this this is just if we
date it's the screen if we connect to my
mother or my sister in Australia it's a
screen yeah
well the problem is that what is
convenient or enjoyable is not always
what's good for you right ice cream for
dinner every single night for the
two-year-old is both convenient and
enjoyable but probably not good for it
the issue is that we are all our own
parents when it comes to our social
media and uh social interaction lives
the pain of rejection whether that be
from a potential friend a potential
partner or a job offer a business
whatever it is is painful and we have
done incredible things to try and Nerf
the world right to wrap it in Cotton
wool so that the pain of rejection is
removed as much as possible this is why
online dating is so successful
because the pain of rejection you don't
know the people that swiped left on you
you only know the people that swiped
right
that's taken the pain of rejection of
dating away right
what do you think of dating apps
do you think they're net positive or net
negative for the world
you really want to go here of course I
want to go okay
I think that dating apps are a perfect
example of something which is both
convenient and enjoyable but not good
for you
they have certainly opened up more
opportunities for people to meet
potential partners
and yet
we are in a world with the highest rates
of sexlessness ever amongst young people
one in three men between the ages of 18
and 30 hasn't had sex in the last year
that tripled from 8 to 28 from 2008 to
2018.
50 of men
say that they are not looking for a
committed relationship that's down from
61 of men saying that they were only
half of men between the ages of 18 and
30 are looking for a relationship you go
okay well if the promises of easy access
online dating were so true how is it
that we've ended up with a world where
people are having less sex than ever
that sex uh sexlessness is also
increased for women too
but for men it's increased more and they
were starting at a higher Baseline as
well
50.1 of women for the first time in
history uh are
mothers there are more childless women
at 30 than there are women with children
right so for almost all of human history
more women had kids under the age of 30
than over and now it's switched
does a study from Morgan Stanley that
says by 2040 45 of 25 to 45 year old
women will be single and childless
if online dating was creating this
perfect facilitation for relationships
to start
how are we ending up with all of these
outcomes
the question
what's wrong with the outcomes
what do you mean why should people care
about being single all the stats you've
just said
um I could look at them and say they're
just sort of objectively neutral like
there's no adverse consequence to
society or the world it's fine that
people aren't having kids it's fine that
people are aren't having sex I'm playing
devil's advocate here but like what what
is the what is the negative consequence
of all of those outcomes that you've
described in your view
there are people for whom a life without
a partner is the right choice
that's absolutely something that I'm
prepared to accept
but it's not most people
it's
one of the biggest levers in fact the
single biggest predictor of your health
outcomes in life are the number of close
connections that you have it's the
number of friends it's more than
quitting smoking it's more than going to
the gym it's more than stopping drinking
it's a number of close friends that
you've got and a relationship is a big
close friend Robin Dunbar says that in
order to get into a relationship you
have to sacrifice two friendships
because you can have around about five
very close friends if you want to get
into a relationship you need to get rid
of two of them because there is a
minimum time investment
so people that are in relationships have
better health outcomes they have onset
of dementia later they have alzheimeric
problems later on in life they are less
lonely
that seems pretty
uncontroversial and yet both sides of
the aisle both men and women are
retreating from relationships and
finding ways that they can justify this
uh you know Boss [__] culture and sort
of the lean in
um women's mentality or men going their
own way and in cell culture and the
black pill for guys are both ways that
each sex is trying to deal with the
challenges that are coming out of the
mating Market
both sexes are saying I don't want to be
a part of this anymore I'm finding it so
painful and difficult to be in this
world that I'm just gonna cast off any
of it altogether and then retroactively
come up with a lot of explanations that
can justify why they didn't need to be
in a relationship in any case and for
some people that's true but for most
people that's not
dating out abs are clearly not you know
as you say in your own words and
previously aren't the only causal Factor
so my question to you is where did we go
wrong and how do we go right
okay so I think challenges in The Mating
Market are coming from many directions
one of the main ones that will be
pertinent to the people that are
listening is the increase in female
achievement in education and employment
now about 50 years ago when Title IX
came in there was a 13 percentage Point
swing in favor of men to women in
universities that were significantly
more men than women it was an
affirmative action uh policy that helped
to get more women into higher education
50 years later 2023 it's a 15 percentage
Point swing between men and women in
University in the other direction there
are two women for every one man at a
four-year U.S college degree around
about by 2030. women on average between
the ages of 21 and 29 earn 111 pounds
more than their male counterparts women
are roughly twice as likely as men to
say that they will value Financial
prospects in a partner about 78 of women
say that a stable job is something that
is important for a partner to have
whereas around about only sort of 45 of
men say the same thing
for a man to increase his uh rating on a
10-point scale by two points he requires
around about a tenfold increase in his
salary for a woman to achieve these same
two-point Improvement on a ten point
scale a salary would need to increase by
10 000 times
my point being that women are
they
are concerned about a partner's
socioeconomic status significantly more
than manner
now you can start to see that if you
have a world in which women are
attending University at high rates they
are achieving uh more success in
employment at least in that sort of 21
to 29 range which is when most people
are perhaps looking for potential
partners
and yet the socioeconomic status of a
partner to a woman is a big determinant
of their level of attraction you can
start to see how this imbalance could
cause a problem similarly when we talk
about education
a man with a master's degree on Tinder
gets 90 more right swipes than a man
with a bachelor's degree
so for all of the guys that are
considering going and getting a master's
degree even if you think it's going to
be useless at least accept the fact that
you get 90 more right swipes for the
rest of your life or just lie about your
Masters I don't know
all of this rolled together
describes something called hypergamy
which is the female tendency to date up
and across on average women want to date
a man who is as educated or as employed
as they are
now in a world in which quite rightly
women have finally been able to achieve
parity in education and employment and
status and have Independence and not be
financially reliant on their partner all
the rest of it that's great for them
but it it does cause some challenges for
their dating and this is what I've
called the tall girl problem so
everybody knows what it's like to have a
girl friend who is six foot without
heels you go if you want to wear heels
you're looking at professional athletes
because on average women want to date a
man who is at least as tall or a little
bit taller than they are so as women
rise up through their own competence
hierarchy in education and employment
they further shorten down the potential
pool of eligible men that are as
educated or more educated and as
employed or more employed than they are
this is a challenge this is just a
straight up imbalance right what this
causes is is a very large group of men
toward the bottom of this distribution
to be essentially invisible to women it
causes a very large number of women in
increasing cohort to compete for an
increasingly small group of turbocharged
super performers at the top these guys
the super high value guys have a wealth
of options so they are commitment to
verse why would they decide to sit down
with one girl for the rest of time when
they have this wealth of options which
can cause them to
use and discard many of these women
which then causes most of these women to
resent men overall and then the guys
that were forgotten at the bottom that
say well hang on a second I didn't use
and discard you I haven't even been seen
by you no no all men are whatever it
might be right that they are users and
abusers that we don't need them that
we're all of the Good Men at etc etc
it's a big group of men that feel like
they are good men that are invisible
there's a big portion of women who have
finally managed to achieve educational
and employment and Independence that are
chasing after a smaller group of guys
these guys are commitment to verse I
don't think it's necessarily good for
them either it's the child with the ice
cream right like guys being able to keep
it in their pants when there's a lot of
options on the table is going to be
difficult for them too
this is one of the main drivers this
tall girl problem is a massive change I
think in the dating Dynamics
it obviously begs a question Chris which
is
if everything you've said is objectively
correct and spot on and supported by the
data then how does if I make Chris
Williamson the prime minister or
president of the world and I say your
first job is to fix this challenge
what'd you do
the first thing that you don't do is
roll back women's education and
employment and this is one of the
problems with this discussion right the
things that I've just said there are
borne out in peer research data Morgan
Stanley results like these are
incontrovertible facts right they are
there and any girl that is listening who
earns more than 50 000 pounds a year and
has got a Masters or above level
education and is toward their late 30s
or in the uh their late 20s or in their
30s knows this problem you know the fact
that you are struggling to find a man
that you feel is eligible for you right
that needs to be out there
the problem that happens around this
discourse is that it posits men and
women as adversaries and competitors of
each other right as enemies
this means that worthwhile
compassion which is needed to both women
and men if you're a woman who has gone
through your education you've dedicated
yourself to achieving a degree you know
your mother's generation wasn't able to
achieve this and you're the first person
that's maybe gone to UNI or got a
Bachelor's I've got a masters I've got a
PhD and then you spend some time in a
career grinding away and you now own 150
Grand a year you think right I'm 31 I'd
love to settle down this would be
amazing for me
where all of the men are hang on a
second and what you realize is that not
only now are you competing with all of
the other increasing cohort of women
that are high Achievers with status
employment and education but you're also
competing with a 21 year old Barista who
still lives at home with her parents for
this small cohort of guys
that requires sympathy for women okay
that is not a good position for women to
be in
at the same time this huge cohort of
sexless men thirty percent of men
haven't had sex in the last year 50 of
men say that they are not looking for a
relationship you were a man you have
been through your twenties you know the
power of the male sex drive between the
ages of 18 and 30. can you imagine
getting yourself into a situation where
you say I'm not bothered about pursuing
women
that is an unbelievably extreme
statement for men to make and their
self-identifying as this in Pew research
data this isn't on in-cell forums this
is pure research 50 of men
aren't looking for a relationship when
they say aren't looking for a
relationship do they mean I'm not
looking for a woman or I'm not looking
for commitment and not actively pursuing
any kind of interaction with women oh
[__]
casual included
what 50 percent
here's the point right you asked about
Solutions the first thing that we need
to do is turn down the volume of
adversarial uh nature between these two
anybody that listens to those two
stories right the plight of men and the
plight of women in the modern dating
world and doesn't see it as
wow that's [__] that that really
really sucks for both sexes
men have it worse in some ways women
have it worse in different ways right
this isn't a competition of like oh
let's wave the flag of who's actually
accumulated more victimhood points
the first thing that needs to happen
before anything is the volume of the
conversation needs to be turned down we
need to see the challenges that are
faced by both sexes the second thing
that needs to be put out front is that
there needs to be a way to raise men up
without bringing women down because it
is very easy for you to say okay so
women are out achieving men in education
and employment let's just put the reins
on them and then everything is going to
be brought back good look
I am not trying to roll back any of the
gains that have been made by women over
the last 50 years
but
you do want to have eligible mail
Partners right if the thermodynamics of
Attraction include the fact that women
tend to want to date across and up in
terms of status employment and education
you need to do something right
some of the things that you could look
at doing in terms of solutions would be
uh
red shirting boys of starting Boys in
school one year later this is something
that was performed by Richard Reeves the
reason for this is that boys tend to
mature less quickly than girls if you
were to start boys one year later in
school it would mean that they would be
more effective at their age they would
be more mature mentally uh that's one
start another one that I think is
probably more controversial but would
make a big impact would be to stop
derogating motherhood right to start
pedestalizing motherhood again there is
a huge movement in
certain corners of women's advice that
any woman who decides to become a mother
is a second essentially a second-class
citizen I don't think that that's true I
don't think that a woman that chooses to
become a mother is a second class
citizen but
women often
fear becoming just a mother right or
just a wife or at worst a domestic
prostitute and they flee from this
Specter of family life into the Open
Arms of a corporate employer and
laughably we call this process freedom
how can it be that
the thing
that most of us
are grateful for a great mother in our
life
has now been derogated as some sort of
uh
it's not it's like somebody's been rubed
into a role that the patriarchy always
wanted them to do
right there was an article a little
while ago that said a maternal instinct
is a myth
that basically the only reason that
maternal Instinct exists is because the
patriarchy has convinced women that
they're actually supposed to like kids
it's like
I can't even begin to explain how
ridiculous that is if you look at all of
the sex differences in terms of the way
that humans work
pedestalizing motherhood would make
women
fear being a mother less it would make
it an aspirational goal for them to to
pursue
one of the scariest stats that I learned
was from a guy called Stephen Shaw he
wrote a did a documentary called birth
Gap
and in it he talks about this declining
Birthright
a meta-analysis by Professor rinska
Kaiser says that 80 percent of women
aren't mothers after their fertility
window closes didn't intend to not be
mothers involuntary childlessness run
about 10 of women are physiologically
incapable of having kids very
unfortunate around about 10 of women
intended to not have children which
leaves a whopping four out of five
non-mother women
who didn't intend to not be mothers and
these women have support groups where
they come together to grieve for
families that they never had and it
breaks their hearts that they weren't
able to find the right partner in time
before their fertility window closed
and Professor Kaiser talks about the
pain
that these women feel and Stephen Shaw's
been to these support groups
that women who thought that they had
more time that struggled to find a
partner in time
they grieve for families that they never
had
and that that sentence just it makes me
it makes me feel so upset like it's so
painful to hear
the prospect of a woman that that wanted
to have a family and couldn't
very difficult
so there's there's two solutions there
that you've kind of offered up as
potential solutions to that
um
does that alone fix the other side of
the coin which is the huge quantity of
men that are avoiding relationships
intimacy women altogether
particularly
um raising man up somehow would be great
but I mean where we begin with that I
don't know I think men are heavily
checked out of Education uh and
employment uh men have been retreating
from the U.S labor force Market by 0.1
percent per year since 1950 87 in 1950
it's about 67 Now by 2050 or 2040 or
2050 it'll be 65 percent
given that women
want on average about 80 of women want a
man with a stable job this Retreat is
not good each step that men take where
they take themselves out of education
and employment
not only isolates them and makes them
economically less
viable as contributors to society it
also makes them less eligible as mates
on average men between 18 and 30 in the
US spend 2 000 hours per year playing
video games
stoned or on prescription drugs
that's not the eligible partner right
so one other thing that you could look
at doing is
re encouraging in-person dating
so online dating does worsen this issue
because it allows you to optimize for
object objective metrics of success
right on a dating app and this is for
both men and women
on a dating app particularly for men you
can have your education level you can
have the car that you're with you can
talk about your job you can
so women are very much encouraged by the
platform itself to take a incredibly low
resolution view of this person so all of
the things that guys are able to work on
like you know Vibe and humor being
Pleasant being kind being caring being
Charming none of that can come across on
a Tinder profile and this means that it
further worsens the tall girl problem
you see how it would it would make the
objective metrics even more and more
worsened let's not forget that there are
three men for every one woman on a
dating app so even if every man matched
off with a woman
there would still be this huge number of
men
that didn't have a partner
right
so online dating hasn't delivered on the
Promises I think that anybody wanted for
it women swipe right on around about 4.5
percent of profiles for men men swipe
right on about 60 of profiles for women
this means that a lot of men see online
dating as
a waste of time we spoke about how it
buffers rejection and that it helps
people to not feel rejection so much but
when you spend a lot of time on apps
swiping right on 60 of people on average
and you don't get very many matches or
any matches or the few matches you do
get never turn into dates
that would quite rightly make people
feel disenchanted with the world of
dating Downstream from the problems of
social media that we spoke about before
are a lack of ability to flirt I
actually think that flirting is a lost
art at the moment you know it's a very
complex thing to do it's a push and pull
it you have to understand a lot of
intricacies about sort of social
dynamics and interaction you need to be
able to tease but not too much and the
Art of flirting is incredibly difficult
to get right and it's even more
difficult if you've never interacted
with a woman in the real world
especially as guys and girls now let's
touch another third rail Stephen me too
so
metoo was a uh necessary requirement to
call powerful men to account for
misbehaving and using their power to
gain sexual access to women
what it sought to do was to sanitize the
toxic elements of certain males Behavior
what it's ended up doing is it's
sterilized almost all of it
84 80 of men report not approaching a
woman because they are scared of being
seen as creepy
84 of women say that they want the man
to make the first move
women are terrified of being approached
by men
because of stories of sexual assault of
dangers within the workplace of
overreach by men that are both in power
and out of power
men are terrified of approaching women
for fear of being accused of all of
those things
so we have
a epidemic of loneliness and sexlessness
amongst the Sexes for the first time in
our four million year history
we have large cohorts of both men and
women who want relationships and can't
get into them
men feel invisible on dating apps and a
terrified of approaching women in the
real world
women yearn for men who they want to be
in a relationship with but either are
not spoken to by or are used and abused
by
in person both of them are terrified of
talking to each other in any case for
fear of either being accused of or
becoming the victim of some sort of
terrible interaction
I think that
re-enabling
in-person dating would make a massive
difference it would reduce down the tall
girl problem because you would have the
ability for guys to gain status in the
eyes for instance a guy that maybe not
doesn't have a University degree but is
unbelievably funny it's still very
statusful right because humor and gender
is a sense of status it's called clown
maxing in the black pill World
um
but that guy might not get a chance if
he was just on online dating
so that would be another thing uh and
you can see as well how
the incredibly uh righteous
ideas of me too
when taken to an extreme
could end up causing some externalities
that
disadvantaged women in the dating Market
do you see what I mean of course as you
were saying that I was thinking about
that video that went viral of the young
girl in the gym who was filming
the guy that came over to ask her if she
needed help with the weights yeah do you
know the video I'm talking about yeah so
for anybody that it doesn't have a
context
um a young lady on Tick Tock
um set up her camera while she was in
the gym and she was filming a guy and
sort of anticipating him coming over to
help and lo and behold the guy walks
over and says do you want to hand with
the way and tries to give her hand with
the weight and then as he walks off she
like she cusses him out and says he's a
basically portrays him as this like
Predator monster and the reaction online
was the inverse the reaction online was
like was siding with the man because he
just came over and asked her if she
wanted a hand of course we both know
that there are very predatory men in
gyms correct I've I've got female
friends that have spoken to that my
girlfriend speaks to that all the time
she tells me how of her experiences in
the gym but there is another side to
highlighting this issue which causes
perfectly reasonable polite men who are
genuinely offering a hand in something
or let's honest flirting yeah to be
totally [__] terrified absolutely and
and this is the this is the difficult
conversation that we don't have a lot
which is what's the the net we can see
the net positive of that we can see the
positive side of that but what is the
downside everything in life has a cost
is that now that we are scared to broker
conversations with strangers through
fear of being put on blast on Tick Tock
if you optimize for absolute safety what
you're going to end up with is nobody
ever approaching a girl in the gym now I
don't know maybe maybe there are girls
that say do you know what it is it is
worth it for no girl to ever be flirted
with in the gym for no girl to ever be
made to feel like they are being uh
stared at in the gym you know like if
the price that we have to pay is that no
one ever gets a date a gym date then
that's fine because the benefit that we
get is that no one ever is made to feel
uncomfortable right
a few things to say on that first off
almost all uh
indiscretions from men that are where
they do creepy Behavior are a very very
small cohort of men that repeatedly do
it this is from David buss's Men
Behaving Badly
it is one man doing a thousand bad
things to women not a thousand men doing
one bad thing to women now the problem
is that that can still cause a massive
that's still a thousand bad interactions
with women right but you have 999 men
that are saying well I don't behave like
that I've been smeared with this with
this bad this bad brush and this is an
incredibly difficult uh line for both of
us to thread here how is it that we can
talk about
some of the challenges that women face
in the dating world when there are so
many obvious benefits that have occurred
to their safety as a byproduct of this
one of the interesting things that I
learned about that uh Jim the toxic Jim
gays video
was
it could have gone either way when it
went on to tick tock right it was a
knife edge if you'd showed me that video
and the comments were hidden
and you said what do you think the
reaction is going to be are you going to
toss a coin toss a coin and that will be
this guy's either push in my opinion I
don't think that he had overstepped but
I don't understand how the world is
going to react to this now the
interesting thing there is that
a lot of people take their cues about
what is and is not acceptable social
behavior from the way that other people
view what is and is not acceptable
social behavior so those sorts of
landmark episodes
actually end up creating a trend of what
people in the real world will consider
to be acceptable behavior so let's say
we have a different version of the
universe and in that Universe everybody
decided that that actually was too much
from a man
what you have then is all of the girls
that watch that video
seeing it and saying oh my God if a guy
glances over at me more than three times
in 90 seconds and tries to help me
deload a glute Bridge
that constitutes worthy uh worthy
concern about abuse and the toxic male
gaze right so we have now reset
expectations down to a much tighter
sensitivity level similarly for men they
think
okay I know that three glances in 90
seconds plus assisting someone to deload
the plates from a bar is too much
therefore at most I can have one glance
during 90 seconds do you understand what
I mean do you see how we we would
further Nerf the world we would wrap it
in more and more and more cotton wool
and then Downstream from that you
concept creep this out to the stage
where anything is toxically masculine
like let's give the other side of the
coin
men overstepping the mark and how men
can be better
um
that's what I that's what I want to make
sure we're balanced in this conversation
because there are as we both have spoken
to there are
um a huge amount there is a huge amount
of inappropriate behavior that happens
throughout Society through the corporate
world throughout everyday lives
how as men do you think we can be better
and when I say better really what I'm
speaking to here is be
is know how to approach a woman in a way
that is not going to make them feel
uncomfortable intimidated
um fearful and that's the the what women
speak to all the time they talk about
how they have to walk home with their
car keys in their hand because if they
pretend they're on phone calls when
they're walking down the street these
are all things that my you know my
sister my female friends have spoken to
so how is men can we be better
the first thing I think is to actually
spend some time
sandboxing this like practicing like you
need the only way that you're going to
learn how to how to interact with a
woman is by doing it it's not the sort
of thing that you're going to be able to
work out on the internet
I mean like basic stuff like don't stand
super close to her don't do it in a dark
alleyway at night
uh don't stare for ages without saying
anything right these are very basic like
rudimentary objective metrics that we
can give but really what it comes down
to is just have a bit of charm about you
understand that if you go up and say
something to a girl hi I just wanted to
ask how your day is going I just wanted
to tell you that you looked really nice
today if there is a girl that has a
problem with that presuming that it's
not in a cul-de-sac Alleyway at the dead
of night and you've got your hood up
right or you're her employer or you're
her employer well here's here's another
interesting one right
right Melinda Gates works for Microsoft
bill is the founder and CEO Bill sees
Melinda around the office this is in the
1980s and he thinks wow yeah she's she's
a bit of all right so he decides to ring
her and say uh Melinda it's Bill
wondered if you wanted to go out with me
one evening and she said uh when when
are you thinking he says how's uh three
weeks tomorrow
you said uh bill I I don't think that
you're spontaneous enough for me I don't
think that this is going to work put the
phone down 30 minutes later he Rings
back and says how's this for spontaneous
you've got the rest of the day off let's
go on a date
2023 founder CEO of large tech company
Rings receptionist asking her to date
him and after she says no
Rings back again pulls her out of work
and takes her on a date
game over right done
where is the line in between Bill Gates
and Harvey Weinstein Weinstein
well it it's precisely in the details
right everybody can say what Harvey
Weinstein did was wrong some people
would say that what Bill Gates did was
wrong but okay is it wrong for two
people a guy and a girl who spend every
day every single time that they go to
the water cooler one of them sees the
other one gets up and like escapes from
their chair so that they get the
opportunity to go to the water cooler
together and they've been doing it for
six months and it's this super platonic
thing but the guy's terrified and the
girls terrified you go okay like should
we Nerf every relationship so that that
interaction can never move to the next
level given the fact that we've got high
rates of loneliness given the fact that
we've got massive amounts of sexlessness
20 of relationships begin on online
dating 20 of relationships begin in
online media social media right
that's two out of five relationships
begin online and they're the most
fragile they're the ones that drop the
quickest they're the ones that stay
together the least long workplace better
friends even better Church even better
than that right but
it is a it is we are in uncharted waters
here people
with regards to the mating world we are
in uncharted waters the Harvey Weinstein
example is where I was like that guy was
a [__] monster well of course yeah
but the Bill Gates want to get it's kind
of like the old-fashioned the
old-fashioned way of doing things you
know when we used to when our worlds
used to be a village and we would you
know maybe write a letter or we'd take
the girl out from the church whatever
but the Harvey Weinstein this guy was a
[__] monster like he was I remember
listening to some of the tapes and the
victims and this guy was a [__]
Predator he was like listen to any of
those really harrowing it's it's it's
it's just it's one of the most
disgusting things I've ever heard where
even like a journalist would come and
interview him
and he would just be like
you know sexually assaulting and
physically assaulting her during the
interview
so this guy just had no boundaries he is
he is just a disgusting moment do you
see what I mean that like quite rightly
there needed to be a reckoning around
that there had to be a reckoning around
that kind of a man using that kind of a
position to get that kind of access yeah
that needed sanitizing that sort of
behavior needed sanitizing and there was
going to be Fallout from it Downstream
from that
how sanitized should Behavior be up to
the point at which it's been sterilized
and there is 84 of women say that they
want the man to make the first move
right
it is still on I mean for the girls that
are listening how many times have you
been the one that's approached a guy
like I've been in nightclubs for 15
years right met about a million people
in there
twice it's ever happened to me that
girls have come up and been like
forthright about chatting me up twice
and I've worked a Thousand Nights in my
it's actually pretty good going yeah two
out of a thousand that's not too bad and
that could also be my fault right like
but
this is very difficult man
and again for the guys and girls that
would say well what does it matter you
know what does it matter that we uh that
people are going to be single especially
for women if you're a high achieving
woman who's got the PHD and I have a
friend
PhD
millionaire self-made millionaire in the
Fitness World mid-30s now going sperm
donor route she's really struggling to
find a partner so she is going to use
her very vast resources to be able to
support these kids to bring them into
the world to have a fantastic life
but make no mistake that's a single
parent household
right that's a single parent household
the outcomes that you have from
single-parent households seem to be
sociosexually the daughter's
don't do particularly well you have high
rates of sociosexuality which is more
casual sex uh more complex complexes
around sex from single-parent households
but what we hear about a lot is that um
education and employment outcomes of
single-parent households on average tend
to be worse for women for the girls in
that situation doesn't really seem to
impact them all that much so however big
you think that effect is double it and
put it just on boys
it's only boys that seem to have that
kind of a problem and quite rightly
you're not going to have a patriarch in
the family that's maybe able to deal
with a rambunctious disagreeable boy
I I don't think
for the women that want to have kids and
you have the resources
absolutely
but for anyone to say that that's the
optimal approach that this is what would
be amazing and again I'm not saying
women become domestic prostitutes take
yourself out of the boardroom and get
yourself back in the kitchen like that's
not what either of us are saying that we
want women to do here
but most people
eight out of 10 women that are childless
once they reach their 40s and later
didn't intend to not be
this is a very difficult conversation
that we need to have to warn people
about the impact of not thinking ahead
in their relationships
you have less time than you think
you need to be aware of that
if I on the other side of the queen when
we're talking about men again if I
delete the dating apps then so you know
first thing we're doing we're deleting
all dating apps that still leaves us in
a world where there's this kind of
pseudo-sexual fake digital relationship
in porn
pornography still exists so I'm
wondering about that 50 of men I'm
assuming and I don't know this 50 of men
but I'm assuming pornography is probably
quite a big part of their replacement
therapy for the connection and sexual um
intimacy that they're missing correct so
I have a theory called the male sedation
hypothesis right
there is a phenomenon called young male
syndrome if you have a large number of
non-partnered childless men in a society
that tends to be an unstable
civilization there's examples throughout
history where
men who don't have a reason to behave
who don't buy into the social contract
of cohesing everything together
tentacles problems they
Revolt they cause riots they spray paint
cars and they push over granny and they
do domestic violence and sexual assault
there have been a number of
in-cell killings of
um
disaffected disenfranchised young men
that have gone out and done horrible
things
but it is not increasing in line with
the amount of sexlessness right it's
tripled 2008 to 2018 tripled eight
percent to 28 the number of associated
young male syndrome incidents hasn't
increased in kind so you think okay
something going on here
something is happening which is causing
men to not enact this uh very well
established throughout all of history uh
response
when men get into a relationship their
testosterone drops when they have kids
their testosterone drops again and
reduce testosterone reduces risk-taking
Behavior
if you've just had a kid you're in a
relationship don't try and jump off that
Cliff because then maybe you've got a
kid that doesn't have a father anymore
can see why that would be adaptive
so the question is why is it that we
have greater rates of sexlessness
amongst young men than ever
but we don't have
this in-kind amount of violence and
disruption and it's my belief that porn
video games and social media are
sedating men out of this status seeking
and reproductive seeking Behavior so I
think that you get a titrated dose just
an Ever So slight just a little little
bit
of reproductive cues from Pawn that
helps to sedate men's desire to go out
and pursue women
I think that what video games do is they
create a sense of camaraderie of
goal-seeking behavior status
within the uh online world
it's
satisfies a lot of what men would have
been trying to achieve with that young
male syndrome
revolution in the past so my belief is
that we have this male sedation
occurring now
given the choice between a society of
men who are dangerous
and a society of men who are sedated
right now
the group of sedated men are
ever so marginally better
but the only reason for that is that
we're at a time of peace
right if there was an alien civilization
that that came down to Earth today
the best thing that we could do would be
to switch off all pawn turn off our
social media we want men to be angry you
want men to be riled up when there is
something that they can direct that
anger at right now there isn't and if
they did it would just foment and it
would cause problems and it would be it
would be bad right so yes the sedating
of this kind of reproductive seeking
Behavior
in a way has made the world calmer
but it's not particularly even say it's
optimal right this isn't great
oh no absolutely not I mean you know the
the uh Advent of the nofap movement men
who identify as not masturbating they
self-identify as not masturbating they
have no faps streaks uh you heard of
this Stephen you've not heard of nofa no
I hang around in the wrong you're on
chronically online how have you not
heard of nofa how have you uh Chris uh
look I I know about my nofa Okay so
there is a very big community of guys
online that have recanted Pawn the same
this is what we were talking about
before right for every movement there is
a counter counter culture for every
um sex positive there is someone that
will decide to push it away for every uh
woman that struggles to find somebody in
the dating Market there is the boss
[__] culture which is the cope then
there is the lean in which is like the
Trad wife thing there is the guy that
becomes the Chad and has sex with all of
the women there is the guy that Retreats
from that and goes men going their own
way and completely recounts it as well
right so you have
the push and pull on both sides
nofap is a group of men who have uh
self-identified as people that don't
masturbate right this is because they
see the impact of Pawn on their
psychological Health on their physical
health and they don't like what it does
to them so they have formed a community
around this
for men who feel like they have a
problem with porn
something that gives them a sense of
pride
about being able to defeat what they see
as a vice is a a place that quite
rightly they're going to get yes I have
control over this even if I don't have
friends even if I don't have a partner
at least I have control over this and it
gives them what are we doing here it is
another goal for men to chase after
right it just happens to be a goal of
not touching your penis it's actually
quite a hard uh thing for a guy not to
do speak for yourself Chris okay even if
I can see where your hands are
um
but there's something I find really
compelling about we've talked a lot
about people that are single that are
searching for love but when you think
about the context of relationship we're
both in relationships
um and the role masturbation plays in
the reduction of desire for our partner
because some of my friends are
struggling with something I've talked
about before with
sex in their relationships I've talked
about my own struggles with sex and
relationships and one of the things
we've kind of diagnosed is pornography
has a
reductive value on the desire we have
for our partners so do we abstain
it depends man I mean people have
varying degrees of sexual drive what's
your approach what's my Approach uh I
think that I I certainly feel like
the story that you tell yourself around
porn and around masturbation seems to be
the biggest determinant of how it makes
you feel and this has been backed up by
a bunch of data from Dr David lay who is
a porn researcher uh coming out I think
he's the University of uh Arizona
perhaps
or New Mexico and
the story that you tell yourself has a
massive impact on
how you feel if you feel like
masturbating
is a
dirty bad uh
action that you shouldn't do that you
should feel ashamed about Downstream
from that you're going to feel shame if
you don't communicate it with your
partner that is a if you're hiding porn
news from your partner that is a huge
huge red flag personally partner is
another concern but for you
it's a big deal because you're going to
feel that sort of disgust self-hatred
shame guilt thing come through
but I do think that if you want to
increase the sex drive in your
relationship just saying okay if we want
to do anything sexual we do it together
try and tell me that that's not going to
increase sex thriving relationship but
you know almost all of the sex that
happens happens in relationships if you
look at how much sex if you took a pie
chart of sex right almost all of it is
in relationships very very small amount
of sex is in casual relationships
as you might know the show's not
sponsored by Airbnb absolutely love
Airbnb always have always been a you
know saved my life on so many occasions
and my team when we first got in touch
with Airbnb were talking about how most
people don't realize that their place
where they currently live could become
an Airbnb and I guess the second
question there is how much could your
place be worth and it turns out you
could be sitting on an Airbnb gold mine
without even knowing it some people
Airbnb their entire homes when they're
away that's what I did in New York
whenever I left New York my place was on
Airbnb and people rented it out
sometimes for a day sometimes for two
days sometimes for a week and it's a
great way to cover some of the bills
while you're away so whether you're
looking to go on holiday or you just
want some extra cash for bills or you
want to buy something nice for a
valentine that you love whatever it
might be head over to airbnb.co.uk host
and you can find out how much your
current property where you live can earn
while you're not there I suspect it
might blow your mind because it
certainly blew mine there was one point
you said about
motherhood and that kind of opened my
opened a doorway in my mind about the
broader subject of regret in life and
you know where if you look at sort of a
meta-analysis of where people at
different ages and different genders are
experiencing the highest levels of
regret where does that fall but no
regret is is something that I've been
thinking about an awful lot
and
it makes for
considering regret considering the
things that we regret in life and trying
to reframe it has been one of the most
useful
mental models that I've gained so
Douglas Murray British writer columnist
spectator multiple New York Times
bestseller I was in Manhattan with him
and he was telling me a story about
Christopher Hitchens the famous atheist
new atheist guy one of the four horsemen
of the atheist apocalypse
and he Douglas earlier in his career was
lamenting to Hitch about the fact that
he had to choose a thing and by choosing
a thing he couldn't do a different thing
so he had this opportunity cost and he's
saying okay all of these problems I
don't know whether I want to do this
thing I want to do that thing
and you can imagine they're probably in
some British pub somewhere in
Westminster or whatever and which is
probably smoking
he goes Douglas in life we must choose
our regrets
and he told me the story and I thought
that's really interesting what does he
mean choose our regrets
and I reflected on it so much and it
made me think well what I'd always
presumed
was that in life
the only reason that I had a regret is
because I made a sub-optimal decision if
only I'd been able to make the perfect
decision I could have ameliorated the
regret and the reason that it's there is
because I didn't make the right decision
but when you accept the fact that
opportunity cost is baked into the
fabric of Life me and you can go to the
gym or we can go to the theme park by
going to the gym we don't go to the
theme park even if the gym was the right
decision to make
we're always going to have the open loop
of I wonder what the theme park was like
that day so I go oh
that's interesting
regrets aren't a bug they're a feature
regrets are a feature of life right they
are a natural byproduct of us always
been curious about what could have been
and given the fact that opportunity cost
exists
they're always going to be there okay
that's interesting it's kind of
liberating right makes you feel less
culpable for
the sub-optimal decision that you made
so but what does it mean that
you have to choose your regrets what's
that what's the choose bit
well
if you accept the fact that regrets are
inevitable that you're going to do
things in your life even if you choose
the right thing and you're going to
consider in retrospect that you wonder
what the other thing could have been
you can't escape regrets
when it comes to making a decision
between multiple choices what you have
to look at is not only what thing do I
want but which regret could I live with
if regrets are inescapable
you have to choose which one you want
okay so I have to choose which regret I
want so you're looking at the choice you
have things in front of you
which of these two could I bear living
with the regret of
and that makes decisions an awful lot
easier right because it switches us from
a place of uh scarcity and fear about
the future
and it helps to project us forward and
think okay which of these am I really
which of these could I not bear myself
to live without so for instance with me
moving to America last year
it was a big move
I'm I was 33 34 at the time
not exactly the archetype you should
have I always felt like I should have
had my [__] together in my life sorted
by the age of 34 so moving to a new
country at this time is a bit oh really
but
if I had the opportunity to do this
podcast to become one of the best in the
world at what I do to pursue my passion
my curiosity
and I didn't do it
I couldn't have lived with that regret
but in that case hindsight's a wonderful
thing right because you could have come
here and it kind of just [__] bombed
it could have done and you would have
then looked back on that decision as
um but at least I don't have the open
loop anymore
right I can live with the regret of
selling an events business in the UK
and
trying to make it work in America and
then going back to the UK with my tail
between my legs and going I gave it a
shot it didn't work
I couldn't live with the regret
of wondering what if I'd had the
conviction to follow my passions and go
out to America and see if I can make it
work
when people are at that fork in the road
the problem is they look off into the
two directions that are in front of them
is both
both directions are completely shrouded
in darkness there's correct so it's it's
that we go down one of the routes and
then you know based on the outcome in
hindsight we then
attach regret or um
pretty much anything I do agree uh but a
few things here people
I've got one particular example in my
mind where I was meant to buy I was
going to buy um it's going to require a
business and we've been acquiring a few
businesses recently at flight story it's
going to acquire a business and I didn't
in the end and it turned out to be a
really really fantastic business and so
in hindsight I'm going I [__] up
that's a regret and I think about it
sometimes I'm like damn should have
bought that business but it could have
gone another way and my my perspective
of the regret now be entirely different
I'd be like I'm amazing I made a
fantastic decision but but the answer
and my like regret didn't come until
the game had been played out and that's
what I'm thinking about with the nature
of regret it's like well it's difficult
right because you are correct if you
take a chance and that chance doesn't
work out then maybe you regret the other
thing but you can you can believe in
advance okay even if I take the chance
and it doesn't work out at least I know
that it didn't work out
for business decisions ones that are a
little bit more easily replaceable as
opposed to Big life decisions you know
I remember when I was uh
much younger 21 I think 22 and I I
needed to decide about whether or not I
was going to go and do the season in
Ibiza I was going to stay at home and
earn and save money and stuff I was 21
like oh 22 I think it doesn't matter you
know what I mean and I I realized even
though I didn't have this model in my
mind at the time I was like this might
be the last time that I get the
opportunity to do this I'm going to go
and do a masters next year and then I'm
going to go straight into running this
nightlife business
I I probably should do this I probably
should and there was just something that
compelled me to go and do it and I went
and spent and the seven weeks that I
spent in Ibiza although I don't remember
all of it my memories of it are quite
fond
and I think [__] yeah like I did I did
the I did the thing and it just helps I
think people to get past the fear of
failure and of regret especially in
retrospect hmm
regret isn't necessarily A Bad Thing the
reason that it exists is because you
cared about something
you cared about something enough to
actually be bothered by it and you know
what when you're describing the
liberating first point of
um the reason why I regret exists it
made me think of this thing I read about
jugglers which I wrote about a little
bit um in my first book where they they
believe that no juggler can juggle more
than 14 balls at once they think there's
just because of the laws of physics the
size of the human hand it's impossible
for a juggler to juggle more than 14
balls at once and that speaks to the
nature of
um limitation there's only a certain
amount of balls you can pick and all the
ones you don't pick and it's kind of
like the old analogous to sometimes talk
about with like I love waffles but I
love a six-pack I'd love to have like a
six-pack or an eight pack or whatever I
can't have both the the story that I can
only have one is what makes either
special yeah
waffles you know like the six-pack is
only great because it's the story of the
waffles I didn't have correct and so I
might regret have but it's but it's
because of the scarcity and the the
nature of us having to make like a
finite set of choices in life that's why
six packs are um having a six pack is so
admirable and it's the same like you
can't have a world where things are
special where you don't have regret
precisely so there's another another
rule that I absolutely love which is
you can have anything you want but you
can't have everything you want yeah
right
you have to sacrifice
most things in the medium term in order
to be able to facilitate progress toward
one thing right uh this is a really
great Insight from Oliver berkman's four
thousand weeks who has he been on yeah
yeah great guy did you when you were
going through that do you remember the
choose and Advance what you're going to
suck at
mindset I can't remember that really
good really cool very interesting uh
mental model to use so you have a uh
plan for the next
six months right or the next year
by doing a thing
other things are going to have to be
sacrificed I want to grow my business
okay maybe your social life is going to
take a little bit of a hit maybe your
Fitness is going to take a bit of a hit
or I want to become I want to get into a
relationship okay well you're probably
not going to be able to get as much
sleep maybe you're gonna have to uh your
business is going to get less of your
attention whatever it might be by
focusing on one thing you inevitably end
up having to sacrifice focus on other
things now the problem that you and me
and maybe a lot of the people listening
to this that are type A go-getters that
want to be able to have it all will feel
is as soon as they start to feel
something slip they go oh [__] [__] [__]
like I'm I'm supposed to stay lean I'm
supposed to say stay healthy and fit and
whatever whatever and you go by choosing
in advance the things that you're going
to suck at the price that you're going
to pay in order for Success within which
whichever domain it is
it allows you to
feel ease
and acceptance when that particular
domain does start to drop away so for
instance this year writing a book
I'm going to do some live shows toward
the end of the year going to continue
doing the podcast and I'm doing some
other bits and pieces as well
my fitness is going to have to take a
hit the start of this year I accepted
the fact that I'm probably going to get
a combination of smaller fatter and
slower throughout this year
but that's fine that's the price that
I'm prepared to pay and I I made that
deal with myself in advance okay I'm
condition Fitness is going to take a
little bit of a hit I'll hold on to it
as best I can this isn't me being
complacent about it I'm going to let it
let it slip and it is such a powerful
Insight that you can have anything you
want
but not everything you want
and I think that's liberating it's all
the things you couldn't have and like I
said a second ago with a six-pack I
often think about a six-pack because I
look I think what makes that socially
valuable if there's a social currency to
it and all it is is lines on your
stomach it's a story though oh yeah I
mean this is the the thing about people
that go to the gym the physique that you
build is attractive feels good when
you're naked and the other person's got
their arms wrapped around you or
whatever right like that's that's a big
part of it don't get me wrong but what
it's also a part of is it shows the kind
of person that you are to be able to
achieve that kind of physique someone
who is self-disciplined who is
self-motivated who can do hard things
who can deal with pain which is like
kind of sexy uh they're conscientious
they're reliable they're disciplined
delay gratification delay gratification
uh all of these things that is the story
which is told by the way that you look
right by your physique
and I really really like that that a
six-pack is a story of all of the
waffles I didn't eat is great and the
same thing goes for
whatever Pursuit you choose you know the
the podcasting thing right and the
differences that you've noticed in your
ability to go from brain to mouth over
the last three years or so since you've
been doing the podcast and mine as well
definitely
that is a story of all of the hours that
I didn't spend
watching Netflix or scrolling Tick Tock
or doing whatever you know it's the days
and days and days of research and
listening back to myself and time with
my speech coach working on diction
sitting in front of a microphone with a
guest doing all of these things and
that's the layers of paint again you
know to look at one of the best
communicators in the world or artists in
the world are dancers or musicians or
Sports people or whatever it is it is a
story of all of the things that they
sacrifice in order to get themselves
there
okay do you want that
don't look at the things that they've
got look at the things that they've
sacrificed because that's the price that
you have to pay to be in that position
when you're alone at night and you're
mulling contemplating when you're in the
gym lifting weights and you think about
the work you still have to do to become
the optimal version of Chris Williamson
what is that what is the work you have
left to do
on a personal level
be mindful
pay attention
be focused be disciplined keep promises
to myself
tell the truth
those are the principles those are most
of the principles
and the reason is we spoke about this
last night
the number of paths that your life can
go down in the future
are so varied and so difficult to
predict that any hard and fast plan will
be completely destroyed by six months of
intense growth
two years ago I couldn't have predicted
that I would be living in America doing
this thing two years ago you wouldn't
have predicted that the show is where
you are and you're on British Airways
and etc etc right so having any rigid
plan isn't going to work having a bunch
of principles is
the things that I still need to work on
in terms of deficiencies are I need to
be more disciplined with my user on my
phone I know that that's a huge Crux for
me
I need to
continue to work on being emotionally
open and vulnerable
specifically publicly uh as someone that
was
very
ashamed about being made to feel weak in
school
that is a large hurdle for me to get
over because I only recently opened up
about bullying with David Goggins of all
people because I felt like you know this
guy's been through so much who is it
what is it for me to say oh I was a bit
lonely in school and like people like
picked on me and stuff
why does that matter
what solving the the vulnerability
hurdle
I think that anything that you are
not
fully prepared to open up about and this
doesn't mean that we're supposed to be
you know transparent to the world around
us
but even to yourself you know to be able
to take the idea the smell the notion in
your head and form it into words
suggests that you haven't
internalized it understood it
transcended it done the work right on it
and also
when you asked at the very beginning
what is it that you're trying to serve
people through the podcast and then
through the work that I do
it's very difficult for people to find a
role model that they can genuinely feel
an affinity with because most of the
people that you look up to
are talented or or successful in some
way and by design that means that you
don't have that much in common if you're
just starting out on your journey
the difference is and the beauty of this
kind of a platform people can scroll
back five years on my podcast on the
Chris Williamson YouTube channel and
they can see episode one in my old
office in Newcastle upon time with a
single Blue Yeti on a 16 pound mic stand
with my friend that was rowing the
Atlantic solo and hear me bumble my way
through an episode as I say every other
second with a different accent with
different lighting and cameras and
skills and everything
so you can track that Journey over time
and you go if you have even a modicum of
admiration or appreciation for many
people
if you can see them from the very
beginning and think wow that's even
[__] than I am
that gives people hope that they can go
through it and I think that
being able to be more
open and vulnerable about the challenges
that I've faced in my past should help
other people to feel less alone now I've
opened up a lot I've opened up about
depression throughout my 20s about the
bullying about all these sorts of things
but it's like okay so where's the deeper
lesson where's the deeper lesson what
else can I take from this
and
I think that would be that would be good
that would be a good thing for me to
to learn and one final thing would maybe
be
uh getting out of my head a little bit
um
we both of us
are
monetizing cerebral horsepower right
like the primary
resource that we have are our thoughts
and then our ability to communicate them
but the problem with that is that it
means that you live a lot of your life
up in your head and the people that are
listening may feel the same you love
listening to Steve's podcast or my
podcast or whatever
okay
how do we go from thought to action it's
what we were talking about earlier on
how do you avoid being so cerebral that
you don't ever get into this sort of
embodied State this really great guy
called Ian mcgilchrist he wrote a book
called The Master in his Emissary
neuroscientist but also a philosopher he
looked at the Isle of Man TT Riders so
the people that don't know Isle of Man
is a small island off the coast of the
UK and these super bikes race around it
but it's potholes and dry stone walls
and B roads and grass verges and every
single year people die and they looked
at the speed of the decisions that the
Riders were making and what they
realized was that it was so quick that
it couldn't be conscious that there
wasn't time for the
prefrontal cortex to get the decision
through
it had to be more limbic it had to be
more ease and Grace so the goal is for
them to get out of their own way right
it's for them to be embodied
and I think that
you know if if you were to say what's
the price that you pay to be
me
one of them would be very very much in
my head
very much thinking assessing over
assessing analyzing and it's beautiful I
love the takeaways that I get I love the
insights that I have
around the world around theories around
mental models around oh my God so if we
look at the fact that
um women want to be approached but men
are scared of approaching because of
this creepiness oh my God there's two
theories and we bring them together and
we go wow that's how Downstream from me
too there can be challenges that are
both created for men and women in this
dating world I'm like [__] that's cool
but the only way that you can do that is
if you think and think and think and
think you're 35. you referenced how
ideas generally are like a smell that
that appears and
gradually we try and figure out where
that smell is coming from
we also talked about regret so bringing
those Concepts together
as a 35 year old man now if you were to
forecast off into the future what your
regrets are what smells of regret would
you forecast now that you're going to
experience when we sit here when you're
14 you go do you know what the mistake I
made at 35. yeah well I mean the
embarrassing thing about this is if you
look back at what you regret from 10
years ago
it's probably still the same [__] that
you regret now yeah I think that I
regret to stay with us because we're the
same you know you are the common
denominator between all of the
experiences in your life
all of my partners all of the breakups
that I go through are bitter and my ex
ends up being a dick okay well what do
all of your exes have in common
you you you're the common denominator
between all of them so I think if
someone is asking themselves this
question and goes
what am I going to regret in 10 years
time what do you regret from 10 years
ago it's a good place to start so for me
um
fearing less
so fear uh making big changes I move
very slowly with decisions whether this
be with uh life whether this be with the
business
um
bringing in team members delegating
control and responsibilities taking
risks doing new things new projects
it served me very well because I make
very few errors in business but I leave
an awful lot on the table because I
don't take risk
so and the reason that I don't take risk
is because of
scarcity mindset fear concern of the
future
um self-doubt you talked about imposter
syndrome The Voice self-doubt self-doubt
to a degree but it is more fear than
that it's just
it's more ambient
than it being self-doubt it's just there
it's just this Cloud that lurks
uncertainty what about the uncertainty
right and this is another thing from
Peterson uh where he says you have to
consider the price you pay for inaction
people presume that inaction has no cost
you don't get to not make a choice not
making a choice is still making a choice
every minute that goes by that this
decision is undone
is a choice I teach you about one of my
favorite Bro Science Concepts that I
came up with
so it's called anxiety cost right you
know about opportunity costs by doing a
thing you don't do another thing
I believe that the longer that you wait
before you do a thing that needs doing
all of those minutes that you spend
thinking about the thing that needs to
be done could have been gotten rid of
had you just done the thing so for an
example your daily routine resets every
morning when you wake up you have to
walk the dog and meditate and do your
breath work and read a new journal and
do whatever
if you do those things earlier in the
day you get to spend the rest of the day
in just this Bliss right this
self-congratulatory Noble High Horse
Bliss about all of these things he did
whereas if you leave them until the end
of the day you have to spend all of
those minutes thinking I gotta do the
meditation when I get home can't forget
to write in the journal that's anxiety
cost and that's a really good compelling
reason why you should make decisions as
soon as you're ready to make them
because you will get rid of these wasted
minutes which you'll never get back
you're never going to get those back
your brief time on this planet 4 000
weeks
and you're going to minimize the anxiety
cost by doing things sooner so for me
definitely fearing less would be one of
them
Chris this conversation has been immense
diverse honest vulnerable everything I
love about this show you're an
incredibly
talented
wise speaker and within that what I see
is I see repetitions I don't see someone
that came out of the womb with your
Insight but I also see a really genuine
curiosity which you just can't fake I
will never be able to fake that I don't
you know we were talking at dinner last
night about the guy sat next to us with
the shoes on and the and you're saying
why is he wearing those shoes and why is
the waitress got that belt on that is
your your sort of natural disposition to
curiosity and it is of tremendous value
for the world because I can take so much
from it without having to do the hard
work and the I think the secondary piece
there is your ability to distill
the complex into the simple that is
incredibly powerful and that's exactly
what you do on Modern wisdom over and
over again and I've I've watched and
observed that show evolve and continue
to evolve into something which is
I mean if I could invest I would invest
I would back that train where that
Train's going so it's I think it's
incredibly important for people to go
and check out your show about wisdom if
they haven't already I'm sure a lot of
people have but it is just such an
unbelievably rich source of inspiration
um
education and Humanity as well and I
think that's a lot of what we lean
towards here is that The Human Side of
these things and you provide that in
abundance so thank you for this
conversation I feel like we could talk
for [__] hours this is the problem
where these things actually have to end
at some point because I'm sure there'll
be a part two in the future I hope
um we do have a closing tradition on
this podcast where the last guest leaves
a question for the next guest as you
know and there's a question been left
for you this is maybe the longest
paragraph I've seen in this book so far
okay so the question left for you is
go back to the most painful or
emotionally challenging moment or period
you had as a boy
what would you say to that boy now
speaking directly to him
to help him through that experience
differences I know who wrote that
question you do yeah yeah it's the
problem of having too many friends in
Austin that fly out here so uh thanks
for that mate
and I have to say we might as well let
the cat out of the bag he also knew that
you were coming on next right so he
wrote that question for you I also
bumped him for coffee yesterday so he
might have written a particularly yeah
yeah yeah sorry
um so
both of us have taken an interest in
psychedelics recently and on
a small dose of mushrooms a long while
ago I saw a version of me in the corner
and what I realized was that that boy
was worthy of love and acceptance and if
I could see
him struggling through loneliness at
school and a lack of
support from Friends
uh a sense of
Solitude that like was pathological
like
just straight up loneliness right
I would have told him that I was proud
of him
for getting through the things that he's
got through
I would have said
you're working hard you're worthy of
acceptance and love
you don't need to offer the world
anything
in order for it to love you back you
don't need to offer people gifts or VIP
entries or insights from a podcast
it's hard to be someone that thinks
about things deeply because there is a
in-kind Association of suffering that
comes along with it like it's both a
blessing and a curse to fill things so
very deeply
but I think that the price is worth it
I think that the depth of enjoyment that
you get out of life is worth it and for
that young boy that I saw that was sat
on the ground that was alone
but I picked him up and killed him and
said
you doing great
Chris thank you
thank you mate thank you so much that's
honestly beautiful and I think
um I speak for many when I say that
that's the message a lot of people in
their own lives will need to hear right
now so thank you so much
I appreciate it I've really enjoyed
coming on it's been great that both of
us are
following this little path
parallel train tracks going forward
just I see where it takes us
over the last couple of how long maybe
four months I've been changing my diet
shall I say many of you have really been
paying attention to this podcast will
know why I've sat here with some
incredible Health experts and one of the
things that's really come through for me
which has caused a big change in my life
is the need for us to have these
superfoods these green Foods these
vegetables and then a company I love so
much and a company I'm an investor in
and then a company that sponsors this
podcast and I'm on the board of recently
announced a new product which absolutely
spoke to exactly where I was in my life
and that is huel and they announced
Daily Greens Daily Greens is a product
that contains 91 superfoods nutrients
and plant-based ingredients which helps
me meet that dietary requirement with
the convenience that hewell always
offers unfortunately it's only currently
available in the US but I hope
pray that it'll be with you guys in the
UK too so if you're in the US check it
out it's an incredible product I've been
having it here in La for the last couple
of weeks and it's a game changer ladies
and gentlemen I am so delighted to
finally be able to announce that one of
my all-time favorite brands are now
sponsoring this podcast and that is
whoop all of you know that I've been on
a bit of a journey in terms of health
performance cognitive performance sleep
and all those kinds of things that's
kind of been reflected in the guests
we've had on this podcast and woof has
been a huge part of my life for many
many many years that's part of the
reason I also had the founder come on
the podcast after having will on the
podcast I love the brand even more
hearing about his vision his passion for
the project where it came from his own
Obsession was solving a problem which
turned into the product that is whoop
whoop is a wearable health and fitness
coach that provides you with the
feedback and real actionable insights
into sleep into recovery into how you're
training into your stress levels and
your overall health and for me it's
empowered me to be the best version of
myself across all of those aspects of my
life the working team have very kindly
offered to give all of you a free month
so just head to join.woop.com CEO to
claim your device and your first free
month on us
[Music]
foreign